everybody's like so hyped up on the fact
that like I post photos were my butts
out
it's a butt everyone has a butt Ariel
winter has a butt and she's proud of it
so proud that she's showing it off again
in a new behind-the-scenes look at her
recent photo shoot I'm now an adult no
longer like a little kid
here's Ariel getting glammed up her
makeup artist strategically focusing on
her booty
she hilariously captioned the pic quote
but really don't miss a spot
hashtag embrace your curves well yeah
when mimic curves are beautiful too the
18 year old loves flaunting her figure
all over social media we've seen her
booty her abs her cleavage and even her
under boob and we gotta admit girl looks
good thank you so much that's really
wonderful et was with Ariel last month
where she revealed why she's so
confident showing off her physique I
don't think it's crazy I get so confused
as to why people make it such a big deal
it's like let me live I'm enjoying my
life you're enjoying your life you
should be posting your but if you like
it too
you